Steve Jobs turned Apple into one of the biggest
companies in the world.
So when he passed away in 2011, people wondered:
What will this mean for Apple?
Good morning.
This is my first product launch as CEO.
I’m sure you didn’t know that.
When Tim Cook took the stage in June 2011
for a special event to introduce a new iPhone,
a seat was reserved in the front for Jobs…in
case he was feeling well enough to attend.
But diagnosed with pancreatic cancer, Jobs’
health had worsened.
The following day, he died at the age of 56.
Apple’s chief designer Jony Ive skipped
the event to be at Jobs’s side, as told
in the book “After Steve” by Wall Street
Journal correspondent Tripp Mickle.
Jobs considered Ive the second-most important
person at Apple, after himself.
Hey Jony
They had lunch together nearly every day.
A typical conversation would go like this:
“Steve used to say to me, and he used to
say this a lot, ‘Hey, Jony, here’s a dopey
idea.’
And sometimes they were.”
Jobs gave Ive the freedom for his creative
juices to flow.
Ive was inspired by the godfather of design
Dieter Rams’s philosophy of creating simple
and functional products.
Yet, after Jobs died, Apple appeared to shift
its focus from design to prioritizing profit.
Cook made Apple wealthy beyond imagination.
The company’s annual revenue quadrupled
from $108.2 billion in 2011 to $394.3 billion
in 2022.
Cook made significant inroads in China and
expanded Apple’s services business.
But despite the expansion of services and
the introduction of new products, THIS is
still Apple’s most valuable product.
And we are calling it iPhone.
The iPhone still accounts for more than half
of Apple’s revenue!
Over the years, the iPhone’s camera improved,
and so have its chips, yet its design has
remained pretty much the same.
To the point that Samsung mocked Apple in
this commercial:
Clip And that epic moon shot that’s getting
all the likes won’t be yours.
Because this innovation is not coming soon
to an iPhone near you.
It’s already here in the Galaxy.
Athough Apple became richer under Cook, the
company has been criticized for being slow
to innovate.
Former Apple sales executive David Sobotta
told the tech news website Readwrite:
"Technology-wise, I think Tim Cook is a lightweight.
I never felt passion for technology from Tim
like I did from Steve and some of the great
engineers.”
Former Apple engineer Bob Burrough told CNBC
that the “dynamic has clearly and distinctly
changed”.
Jobs was known for constantly pushing the
design team.
He once walked past a prototype of an upcoming
iPhone that he didn’t like, and said to
an engineer: “What is this sh*&?”, a remark
characteristic of his candid demeanor.
Jobs also insisted that the iPhone needed
to be changed from plastic to glass, even
though the design team worried that glass
would crack easily.
Jobs insisted and told Jeff Williams, Apple’s
Chief Operating Officer, “I don’t know
how we’re going to do it, but when it ships
in June, it’s going to be glass.”
When Ive presented the initial iPad prototypes
to Jobs, the rectangular design seemed too
harsh.
They opted to round the edges, making it easier
to slide a finger underneath and lift from
a table.
Jobs spent much of his time discussing prototypes
by the long wooden tables outside Ive’s
office.
On the other hand, Cook hardly swung by the
design studio.
And when he did, it wasn’t for long.
Cook explained to ESPN: “I knew what I needed
to do was not to mimic him.”
“I would fail miserably at that, and I think
this is largely the case for many people who
take a baton from someone larger than life.
You have to chart your own course.
You have to be the best version of yourself.”
He decided to focus on business and operations.
Cook would wake up before 4 am to review sales
data.
He’d want to know why a certain iPhone model
was outselling another model in a given city.
Before becoming CEO, he was Apple’s chief
operating officer, responsible for managing
the global supply chain.
He’s credited with streamlining Apple’s
manufacturing process, which cut costs significantly.
He minimized the amount of inventory Apple
held at any given time, something he learned
at IBM…where he was responsible for securing
components to make PCs.
He once declared: “Inventory is fundamentally
evil.”
Likening it to dairy products; he believed
they should be viewed as perishable and not
be allowed to sit around for too long.
There wasn’t much doubt who Jobs would pick
to succeed him.
Cook exuded calm and listened more than he
spoke.
Ive reportedly did not want the top job and
was more comfortable focusing on design rather
than the business side of running a company.
The only other serious contender for CEO was
Scott Forstall the head of software design.
However, his ego and history of conflicts
ruled him out.
And then Cook pushed him out of the company
after the disastrous launch of Maps that Forstall
oversaw.
And it is beautiful.
The maps were rife with errors.
Cook even had to issue an apology.
With Forstall gone, Cook handed oversight
of software design to Ive, which put more
on Ive’s plate.
One of Jony’s big ideas was adding the control
center that lets you swipe from the top or
bottom of the screen.
Engineers originally said it couldn’t be
done.
But Ive insisted.
After Jobs’ died, there were critics who
questioned Apple’s ability to innovate.
They desperately needed a product to wow the
world and silence the doubters.
In 2012, Ive arranged for Apple’s top executives
to meet at a hotel in San Francisco to discuss
a wearable device with health sensors.
Noticeably absent from the meeting…was Tim
Cook.
He sent a message saying he had no plans to
try to fill the shoes of his predecessor.
Cook delegated responsibility to Ive and to
the head of operations, Jeff Williams.
The Apple Watch was the company’s most personal
product, and as a result, it came with different
watch bands and various colors so people could
customize it.
The digital crown to expand and contract the
app icons paid homage to the traditional watch
design and blended together the past and the
future.
It is the next chapter in Apple’s story.
And here it is.
Cook unveiled the Apple Watch in September
2014, three years after Jobs’ death.
Although the excitement was palpable at the
launch event, the media’s reaction was lukewarm.
A Bloomberg headline put it this way: “You’ll
Want One, but You Don’t Need One.”
Ive anticipated Apple needed to make 40 million
watches in the first year to meet demand,
but Apple only sold around 12 million watches
in 2015.
The Apple Watch did gain traction over time,
and Cook said it leapfrogged Rolex to become
the most popular watch on earth.
The Apple Watch sapped a lot of energy out
of Ive, who had to oversee industrial design,
software design, and marketing - all without
the collaboration of his creative soulmate.
(show Jobs)
Ive felt as if he had to fight hard for his
vision, like convincing the marketing team
that the watch needed to be marketed as a
fashion accessory rather than as a tech device.
The watch would eventually shift from fashion
to fitness in an effort to boost sales.
Ive told the New Yorker that he’d become
“deeply, deeply tired” and that the year
leading up to the Watch’s debut had been
“the most difficult” he’d ever spent
at Apple.
Just like Cook’s ability to squeeze more
out of suppliers, the CEO appeared to be squeezing
more out of Ive…who took a three-week vacation
in Hawaii to unwind - the longest break he’d
had in years.
(Kauai)
Tripp Mickle’s book describes how Ive wanted
to leave Apple, which alarmed Cook, who didn’t
want to lose the world’s most famous industrial
designer.
The solution was for Ive to step back from
day-to-day management and shift to a part-time
role, focusing on future projects such as
designing Apple’s spaceship-like headquarters.
Two designers who reported to him would be
given more daily responsibilities.
(Richard Howarth and Alan Dye)
Then there was the question of what would
be Apple’s next big thing.
Launching a successful electric car would
blow away any doubt about Apple’s ability
to innovate.
At the time, Tesla was doubling its staff
and developing more sophisticated batteries
for its electric vehicles.
Tesla was also recruiting dozens of Apple
engineers.
Jobs had reportedly shown interest in building
an Apple car as early as 2008.
Apple hired hundreds of engineers to start
working on the secretive “Project Titan”.
Ive envisioned a fully self-driving car where
passengers would hop in and tell Siri where
to take them, and off they went.
But, as Apple found out, building an autonomous
car is extremely difficult.
And there was no passionate leader like Jobs
to spearhead things.
Apple’s research and development spending
in 2015 hit $8 billion, with the secretive
car project undoubtedly eating up a huge chunk
of that budget.
As it stands now, reliable Apple analyst Ming-Chi
Kuo believes it's unlikely an Apple car will
hit the market before 2025.
Apple then turned its attention to another
product.
Wireless earbuds would further free people
from their iPhones, as the Apple Watch had
done.
Ive’s design team had brainstormed the idea
of AirPods back in 2013.
When they first came out, people thought they
looked a little ridiculous.
Comedian Conan O’Brien poked fun at their
potential for falling out of peoples’ ears.
Really?
Ugh, fine
Despite the issues, the AirPods quickly gained
popularity for their sound quality and seamless
integration with the Apple ecosystem.
Yet, it was clear Ive’s influence was diminishing.
He had little to no say when Cook selected
a new board member to replace a longtime confidant
of his, Mickey Drexler.
Cook named James Bell, Boeing’s former chief
financial officer, to Apple’s Board, which
addressed a lack of diversity.
Ive supported diversifying the Board but preferred
someone with marketing expertise over finance.
Mickle’s book says a colleague defending
the pick of Bell told Ive, “He’s an underrepresented
minority.
He has a great reputation.”
Ive reportedly responded: “Who cares?
We have to be concerned about the company.
He’s another one of those accountants.”
The appointment could be seen as demonstrating
Cook’s political adeptness.
He was Apple’s chief diplomat; he charmed
the pants off Chinese ministers to secure
government approval to use the iPhone on the
country’s largest wireless carrier.
He navigated in an environment in which President
Trump vowed to bring jobs back to America
which was worrying for a company that benefitted
from China’s cheap labor.
Cook had masterminded the outsourcing of Apple's
production to China through the Taiwanese
company Foxconn.
There was significant controversy after a
spate of suicides in the 2000s and 2010s tied
to brutal working conditions in Foxconn factories.
Nets were installed to catch people as they
fell.
Apple has taken steps to address the working
conditions, including conducting regular audits
and inspections.
85% of Apple’s Pro lineup of iPhones is
reportedly made in ‘iPhone city’, a sprawling
campus in Zhengzhou, China, that employs as
many as 300,000 people.
Depending heavily on China hurt Apple as COVID
restrictions delayed iPhone shipments.
Apple realized it had to diversify and is
now trying to open up iPhone cities in India
and Vietnam.
Cook also had to manage many issues unrelated
to product development.
Like the time the FBI demanded Apple unlock
an iPhone used by one of the shooters in the
San Bernardino attack in 2015.
Apple resisted, citing user privacy concerns.
The FBI managed to access the data through
the help of a third party.
And in 2020, Fortnite creator Epic Games sued
Apple, accusing it of anti-competitive practices.
Apple had removed Fortnite from the App Store
after Epic Games allowed in-app purchases
in Fortnite, bypassing Apple's 30% commission.
So while Tim Cook was very busy, he spent
little time coming up with Apple’s next
big product.
Instead, Apple made changes to its existing
lineup, like removing the home button for
the iPhone X.
But the iPhone X was also delayed due to issues
with the facial recognition system.
Let’s try that again.
The delays coincided with Ive not being in
the office every day.
According to Mickle’s book, Ive moved some
meetings off campus, to a private club in
San Francisco, which apparently irked some
Apple executives.
They were also reportedly not happy that Ive
was believed to be getting paid much more
than them.
Each member of the executive team earned about
$25 million annually, which was publicly disclosed
to comply with the SEC's requirements.
However, Ive avoided being classified as an
officer, and as a result, his compensation
was kept secret.
Some senior Apple employees felt the best
days were behind them.
When top software designer Imran Chaudhri
prepared to leave the company in 2016, he
sent a farewell email and quoted the poet
Rumi: “When you do things from your soul,
you feel a river moving in you, a joy.”
He then played off that line by writing: “Sadly,
rivers dry out, and when they do, you look
for a new one.”
The comments infuriated management, including
Ive, and Chauhdri was fired.
Another employee who left, Chris Stringer,
was a top designer unhappy with Apple’s
smart speaker.
He believed Apple treated the HomePod like
an afterthought rather than a signature product.
The HomePod has lagged far behind the popularity
of Amazon’s Echo and Google’s Nest.
Ive realized how much his team struggled without
him and decided to return to a more hands-on
role in late 2017.
Yet…it was never the same again.
The successors to the iPhone X ten looked
almost identical.
Cook had hoped the lower-quality XR would
do well in China, but it bombed partly due
to competition from Huawei.
In January 2019, Apple released a letter from
Cook to investors, reducing the company’s
quarterly sales estimate for the first time
in 16 years.
Apple lowered revenue guidance to $84 billion
instead of the $89 billion to $93 billion
it had previously projected.
Cook blamed the economy and trade sanctions,
but the reality was, people were also getting
tired of only incremental changes to the iPhone.
Apple noticed customers who usually upgraded
their phones every two years were not doing
so nearly as often.
Despite the challenges, Apple had a milestone
to look forward to that year, in 2019, as
it prepared to celebrate the formal opening
of its new headquarters in May.
However, a day before, Ive’s dad had a stroke.
He rushed to the UK to be with his father,
who thankfully recovered.
Jony owed his career to his father, who had
taught design at UK schools and nurtured his
interest in design.
For Jony, it appeared time to consider returning
to the UK for good with his wife and twin
boys.
A month later, in June 2019, Ive gathered
a group of his designers and told them he
was leaving Apple.
He explained he’d grown tired of the company’s
bureaucracy, as reported by Tripp Mickle.
Mickle writes in his book that Ive told the
team: “I don’t want to go to any more
f*&^ing meetings.”
The design team would now report to the chief
operating officer, Jeff Williams.
Ive’s foot wasn’t fully out the door,
however; he set up his own design firm alongside
Marc Newson, an influential designer at Apple
who worked under his guidance.
LoveFrom would consult for Apple.
The contract was reportedly worth $100 million.
Although Ive hoped the relationship between
his firm and Apple would last for “many,
many years to come”, as he told the Financial
Times, that would not be the case.
In 2022, Apple and Ive parted ways for good.
Steve Jobs was well aware that great companies
faltered after their founders departed.
It happened to Disney after the absence of
Walt’s leadership, and to Sony when co-founder
Akio Morita stepped down as chairman.
Jobs told his biographer Walter Isaacson:
“The company does a great job, innovates
and becomes a monopoly or close to it in some
field, and then the quality of the product
becomes less important.
The company starts valuing the great salesmen,
because they’re the ones who can move the
needle on revenues, not the product engineers
and designers.
So the salespeople end up running the company.”
Has his worst fear come true?
When working on stories like this that take
a significant amount of research, I know how
important it is to get a good night’s sleep
to keep my mind sharp and productive.
I’ve noticed my sleep has gotten better
since I’ve been supplementing with magnesium
which I’ve been taking for a year now.
I had no idea that 75% of people are magnesium
deficient, which can lead to higher levels
of anxiety, irritability, low energy, and
trouble sleeping.
Magnesium is involved in more than 300 chemical
processes inside your body.
So a lot of different things can start to
go wrong if you’re deficient.
It’s also important to get the right kind
of magnesium.
I recommend Magnesium Breakthrough by BiOptimizers.
It’s the only organic full-spectrum magnesium
supplement that includes 7 unique forms of
magnesium.
Visit magbreakthrough.com/newsthink and order
now.
And in addition to the 10% discount you get
by using my promo code NEWSTHINK10, there
are always amazing gifts with purchase.
Go now to magbreakthrough.com/newsthink to
get your Magnesium Breakthrough and find out
this month's gift with purchase.
The link is in my description.
Thanks for watching.
I’m Cindy Pom